hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher systemically I think a huge
challenge that teachers face is a lack
of time to devote to professional
learning and that pressure internal
learning doesn't necessarily have to
look like sitting listening to a seminar
being able to read and engage with some
research it's often those conversations
we have with our colleagues who are
usually the best resource we have access
to but we are to hide and busied and
running to every next deadline and the
huge number of kids that we have a
responsibility to which makes it
difficult to invest him in those
processes which might not be urgent but
they're hugely important so I think it's
really valuable if schools are able to
provide that time that environment for
teachers we all say ok I'm going to hit
pause on all the rush of what's
happening in a school and and ignore the
bells for a minute and be able to say we
need to have a conversation about but
where our practice affects our students
and how we can improve that I think
those conversations and discussions and
even yes that engagement in research is
so vital and without it as teachers we
are just going to become demoralized and
detached from our our own growth as
professionals and our own mastery as
teachers and I think being able to feed
that is one of the best ways to
encourage teachers to continue in that
fight and become better and better and
work for their students in a more
effective way
[Music]
you